I've always told everybody cuz for
whatever reason I've told you this
before I I think people think like we're
a lot closer friends than we are and
we're cool like you're my boy you know
like you've thrown some lobs my way that
I appreciate I don't talk to that many
people in general but people like hit me
up like what's up with your boy he's a
[__] cuck this is weird and I'm like
I don't know dude maybe like and this I
always this why I always say you guys
have been [__] women on camera right
for so long uhhuh one dick comes out of
left field and it's like all of a sudden
they just act like you guys aren't sex
workers or performers or whatever you
want to call it like even when we had
our kid I don't really remember like
almost anybody throwing it in our faces
and being like you shouldn't have a kid
you're a porn star y yada whereas now it
feels like every time all you hear it's
all people want to do is just tell me
about how I'm like violating the
sanctity of traditional marriage and
like everyone just kind of like
willfully ignores the fact that we do
porn and are let's be honest clearly
trolling slash Hamming it up to get as
much media attention as possible on plug
talk right which worked yeah yeah I
think uh I I mean that clip you guys
sold with the Jason love had to be one
of the more I think you had told me it
was one of the more successful things
ever sold on that platform right the
biggest only fan scene of all time
ever
ever seven figures of
course eight figures I I wouldn't want
to take that leap you never know though
in between like around the
five that's a lot dude what do they keep
like I always wonder what is only fan
what's their cut 20% so they're keeping
20% yeah damn so they're eating off
everybody that's [__] great there man
only fan that's such a great business
model insane right damn I remember when
they were going to go away and then all
the fake only fans popped up yeah and we
spent like 30 grand to get a [__] uh
plug talk website built and then by the
time it got done only fans seemed a lot
more stable and so we never even ended
up making the website go live we figured
let's just stick to only fans yeah it's
almost like if YouTube went away you'd
have to figure some [__] out like only
fans is kind of like the new like
standard if you're a content creator
even yeah in the porn industry and I
even know girls like some of the biggest
girls in the industry who have their own
website ready at to go and they just
keep it on the back burner because only
fans is just so much more familiar to
the users that it's just it's a layup
like it's just it's just so much more
effective to put your content on there
it's kind of sucks you can't necessarily
like present it exactly the way that you
want to present it like you would be
able to on a website but they go to your
website they got to put in their credit
card information they go to only fans
credit card information is already in
there for like almost everybody who
would ever think about buying porn right
true yeah and it's kind of like if
you're going to go on YouTube to watch
like all your content why would you go
sign up for I mean like shout out to
rumble no D to rumble but I'm not
[__] watching nothing on Rumble I
mean I would if it came down to it but
yeah like if you had to if I had to I
would go to rumble but it would take a
lot yeah it would take a lot especially
like if you got like booted off the
platform or something yeah exactly has
happened with I think what Steve will do
happen happen with him yeah it's it's
good to have a backup but I don't know
um do you guys get to see like uh like
the top earners cuz we saw the celebrity
top earner of the Year thing on fans are
you able to see on the back end like
where you rank at the end of the year
they tell you your like percentage like
like you get to see top 1% yeah but they
don't give you any more information than
that because it would be that would be
pretty crazy if we were able to be like
well we make a little bit more than you
and you but not as much as you that
would be cuz I I I feel like some of
these celebrity numbers have to be
inflated I think a lot of people lie
about it and I've like the bad baby
numbers are so [__] insane yeah I
don't know a weird part of me kind of
believes her numbers just because as
ridiculous as that $18 million month
looks it just kind of seemed like when I
when I saw how it went from like 18
million to like 800,000 as the months
went by I was like that seems like a
normal rate of uh you know degrading of
of income but I don't know if you saw
the guy who was like Ruby Rose's number
one I saw you just interview with him he
said it was cap right yeah and so I feel
like I think he's full of [__] oh no no
no that's that's a funny reaction that a
lot of people keep having to it is that
they think he's actually now covering up
for his own perversion but let me tell
you I've known this guy for a long time
so you know him I I've known him because
he used to be a an assistant to a tattoo
artist who did some work on me he one
time came to the store in like 2018 and
he did a a dab with lean instead of
water uh I guess he was just trying to
get some attention doing that or
whatever and the thing about him that
really made me realize it was fake is
well number one one of the top dudes at
only fans corporate told me it was fake
and then after that I realized just that
he knows a lot of the porn star girls
that I know like he was on FaceTime with
Gina Valentina right after our interview
just talking on some regular [__] so
it's like he doesn't seem like the kind
of guy and and also I don't think he has
the kind of money that it would require
he supposed to be a crypto whale I think
yeah that's you think that's all
[__] yeah no so cuz he was I saw a
picture he didn't get a Ruby Rose Tattoo
he did get a Ruby Rose Tattoo I don't
know which is kind of funny cuz I doubt
she would ever want to really see him
again that's very uh that's that's
committing you want to know something
super funny oh my God I feel bad
actually I feel bad even calling it
funny but he had a whole week of media
planned out right he was going to do
Vlad he he he flew to Miami to do
freshman fit immediately after our
interview and he was supposed to go on
that whatever pod we've been dming each
other well there's another one that
probably isn't going to happen I would
assume but like the whatever pod when I
went there yesterday he asked me about
that guy I told him it was fake he goes
oh we're probably just not going to have
him on then I'm like oh whoops Vlad I
think canceled on him as well F and he
flew out to do fresh and fit and they
canceled on him when when he after he
already flew out there but I I
understand why because what the [__] are
you interviewing this guy about if it's
all fake yeah especially I mean shout
out to Ruby Rose if this was her team
like hiring some dude it [__] worked
yeah I don't know I mean it's not a bad
idea I told Micha girl right away as
soon as I saw that I was like we should
do this we should say that some guy give
us 100 Grand let's just up the find some
dude hire him some [__] dude that's a
nobody who doesn't have any relationship
media presence they made it seem kind of
real with the screenshots of the oh with
the texting and [__] like weird dude
from only fans that was smart they they
and even this right here is kind of like
another round of attention on Ruby
Rose's only fans even if it's and I've
noticed too like you'll scroll on like
uh Hollywood unlock and they'll have
these fake stories about like teacher
gets fired from their only fans account
but it's really like we banged her oh no
no but I'm not even talking about that
one cuz that was a real one there's been
so many cuz we talk about [__] on the
radio and my my boy will be like oh this
is uh some some somebody got fired from
their job or whatever or and then we'll
look and'll be like oh this is a paid ad
oh yeah and now Twitter will add a
community note oftentimes informing the
public of oh this is fake like this
account got paid to post this this is
only fan promotion yeah so shout out to
that's a very useful service right there